[Music]
i want to start with a big thank you
thank you for deciding to listen to this
podcast episode
more important and relevant to our topic
at hand i want you to think about the
other decisions you made throughout your
day prior to listening in
chances are you've made many many
decisions some big some small some
personal and some business related today
we're going to discuss how we can make
better
decisions i'm matt abrahams and i teach
strategic communication at stanford
graduate school of business welcome to
think fast talk smart the podcast
i am really excited today to be joined
by both jonathan burke and jules van
binsbergen jonathan is the ap giannini
professor of finance at the gsb
jules is the nippon life professor in
finance at wharton
together jonathan and jules host a new
podcast entitled all else equal i've
listened in and i've learned a lot
thanks for being here jonathan and jules
it's great to be with you math thank you
so much for having us
and it's an honor to be here
great well thank you both let's get
started so jonathan you and jules have
worked together for a long while and
published many papers together i'm
curious
what led you to podcasting and what is
the focus of your podcast
in a nutshell our podcast is about
making good business decisions
we both feel that people make common
mistakes repeatedly and often what makes
this worse is that have no idea they're
making a mistake
at the same time we hear business gurus
providing advice often either flat out
wrong
or platitudes like treat your employees
well we thought we could just do better
we could provide substantive advice
based on research
in fact in each episode we will start
with a business decision that people
make that they feel is obviously correct
we will explain why it is a mistake and
hopefully by the end of the episode our
listeners will think that the correct
decision is obvious
this might sound like a tall order but
you'd be surprised how often people do
things in business that are obviously
wrong without realizing it well i
certainly have seen a number of leaders
make mistakes and what i find so
wonderful about your podcast is that you
actually get people to come in and talk
about their mistakes and you help others
avoid those mistakes and learn how to
make better ones so i i've listened and
i think it's fantastic and i encourage
everybody to listen in uh jules given
that you both are focused on helping
people make better decisions can you
share a specific idea or lesson you've
learned that can help us in this area so
i think that when making a decision
people often have a mental model of the
world that is static or fixed but the
world just doesn't work that way it's
it's highly dynamic
and when i say that i don't just mean
that changes happen around us
continuously that we have to somehow
deal with what i mean is
when you move a piece on your chessboard
the whole game changes and the rest of
the world who's on the other side of the
chessboard will respond to that move you
just made so there are two ways of
thinking about the chess game of life
first think about you being allowed to
make the next 10 moves without the other
side responding you can win that game
quite quickly and it isn't all that hard
but now think about the other player
responding after every move you make
this is a very different competitive
game it is much harder to play that game
and you have to think very carefully
about the moves that you want to make
that thought process can be really
frustrating but ignoring those dynamic
effects doesn't really get you anywhere
it simply is the reality we have to deal
with and because we think this mistake
is so common and important we decided to
call the podcast all else equal because
there are many statements that are true
when you can hold all else equal but in
the real world all else is never equal
and then suddenly these statements no
longer hold and they can lead you astray
i get it i was wondering where you got
the name of your podcast but but thank
you while i'm a lousy chess player i
totally understand what you mean and i
think the the focus that you have in the
approach you take can be really helpful
i'd like to follow up though jules um
what advice do you have on how we
actually can go about communicating the
mistakes we make well let's start by
saying it's really hard i think we can
both agree on that absolutely the most
important thing you need to do before
communicating a mistake is thinking
through what happened carefully what in
business language i think is often
called do a root cause analysis why did
that mistake happen and what can i learn
from that because admitting mistakes is
hard enough as it is and many people
will try to avoid doing so because they
experience it as a humiliating thing if
you go to your manager and simply admit
the mistake and then your manager asks
can you help me understand what happened
and why you better have a good answer if
you have the explanation as well as your
plan for the future ready at that point
you can actually come out of the
conversation stronger and you can turn
it into a positive experience that isn't
humiliating so it sounds to me like two
things that are important there one is
approach mistakes as part of learning
there's value to be taken from the
mistake so you can avoid it or do things
better in the future and then do that
root cause analysis to really understand
so instead of avoiding and running from
it or hiding from it i don't know if
embraces the right word but at least
accept it and and then figure out what
went wrong is that what i heard you say
absolutely but what the second thing is
don't follow the first mistake with the
second mistake to not come to the
meeting in which you're supposed to
explain the first mistake prepared be
prepared so that you've done the
analysis before going into that meeting
so that you can immediately give it a
positive twist as opposed to just being
a bad experience for you in which you
feel bad well that echoes a lesson we've
talked a lot about on this podcast which
is take the time to prepare it can
really help jonathan i'd like to turn to
you allow me to ask you the same
question i asked jules can you share a
best practice for better decision making
well we called the podcast or else equal
because he wanted to highlight a common
and costly mistake that comes up in many
business contexts
when you make a decision you have to
take into account the effect of that
decision on the world too often people
ignore that they engage what i would
call or else equal thinking and they
evaluate the effect of the decision
holding everything else the same you can
never do that
i know it sounds obvious as i talk about
it but you'd be surprised how often
in the context of a decision
people get fooled
we're going to explore many of those
contexts on the show i think that is so
important to understand that the
environment is dynamic and you need to
be able to adjust and adapt to what's
happening and not have fixed thinking so
uh clearly something that people can
learn from you in your podcast
when i coach non-finance executives and
senior leaders they often dread and
perhaps even fear their interactions
with those in finance like the cfo for
example
because they often get their proposals
rejected or feel that they need to do
battle
i've heard you talk about this as a
communication challenge in terms of
framing and language can you share your
thinking on this type of communication
yes absolutely so i think the first
thing to establish is we think through
language if we don't speak the same
language it's very difficult to align
our thoughts so let's start with that
so and for that reason i think that one
of the reasons why regardless of their
major
a business school student should learn
finance and some of the math that comes
with it is that you learn the language
of quantitative dynamic decision making
how do you know whether something is a
good decision unless you have properly
traded off the upsides and the downsides
or what economists or finance people
call benefits and costs the discipline
that finance brings to the table really
helps with that particularly when the
costs and the benefits happen at
different times
so i'm not saying that everybody has to
learn all the nitty gritty details of
finance but you do need to understand at
least at a conceptual level what goes
into making a good decision and why
quantities are important in that not
just qualitative arguments now on the
other side and that's the other side of
the the communication challenge i think
it's important for quantitatively
oriented people to translate their
insights into plain english
it is easy to make finance sound
completely incomprehensible by using
tons of jargon and acronyms which is
really unnecessary as far as i'm
concerned i think a very large part of
teaching say the core finance class is
to make people familiar with the jargon
and really show them that once you
translate this jargon into plain english
most of these concepts are really quite
simple
that's so powerful what you said i mean
we both sides of the interaction in any
communication need to speak the same
language we need to avoid jargon we need
to make sure that the terms are
something that both understand
and we have to take time to learn the
perspective of the other what's
important to them i think it's fantastic
that two professors of finance have said
you know what we need to speak just in
plain english to help people understand
so thank you for that thank you now
speaking about how we think about things
jonathan i know you have spent a lot of
time thinking about how we think and
even further how we go about teaching
others how to think better
what thoughts do you have on this
particular topic that you can share well
this is going to be an important theme
of a podcast series
it's pretty easy to talk about best
practices but putting them into practice
is really another matter completely
right we are emotional creatures and our
emotions materially affect how we make
decisions
for example we learn best when we make a
mistake and recognize that we have made
the mistake but for most of us it's
really difficult to admit that we made a
mistake
so an important part of teaching is
understanding that emotions often stand
in the way of learning
of course i do this myself all the time
that is i let my emotions get in the way
of learning and growing
now the best way to teach something is
by modeling so part of teaching
is making sure to model the behavior so
admitting that when you make a mistake
and
showing students how you can learn from
your own mistakes you know when i do
make a mistake in the in the classroom
i'm always very careful i try to be very
very careful to be completely up front
about the mistake
how how i made it so students can see
you know
nobody knows the material perfectly and
it's through the mistakes that you
really get this deep understanding i
think the notion of how emotions affect
us in almost everything we do is
critical especially when it comes to the
way we think and modeling is so
important and the willingness and and i
really
i i strive to do the same thing you do
that when a mistake is made to
acknowledge it to learn from it and to
help others feel more comfortable
not only taking the risks they need that
might lead to mistakes but when they
make the mistake to acknowledge it and
learn from it so that's really important
information and i think can help us all
in not only in our decision making but
in in most of our interactions given the
wide variety of topics you both teach
and study do you have any last best
practices advice or frameworks you'd
like to impart to us
well you know i have strong views about
teaching and education
you know i think that the way we go
about educating is really an historical
accident that was constrained by the
technology that we had for most of uh
human existence
the fact is people do not learn at the
same pace nor do they learn the same way
so our traditional way of learning where
we teach everybody at the same pace and
the same way i don't think is that
helpful uh also don't think we learn by
being lectured to really the way human
beings learn is by doing so you know i
changed the style that i taught about a
decade ago
and i guess with the colloquial name for
how i teach is the flipped classroom
students do the homework and read the
book before the lecture and in the
lecture we practice by working problems
so i'm trying to teach by doing this
notion of flipping the classroom that
where people do the work in advance so
you can actually engage in the the
material
in person is a great tool for teaching
but i would also argue in business
settings and business meetings the same
thing applies instead of doing updates
where all you do is recount information
have people do that on their own time in
advance so when you come together you
can collaborate to discuss and decide so
the notion of a flipped classroom which
i think is very powerful for education i
think also applies in the business world
as well
one way to learn the quickest is by
teaching
and so you can take the flipped
classroom even one step further so so in
in the last semester that i taught what
i did was on the last class i had to
students teach the material
to the class
brilliant so in in that way they had to
formulate in their own words what they
thought the most important things were
that they learned throughout the
semester and and i had a very good
experience with it i would recommend it
so there's actually a teaching technique
jules that is based on what you just
said it's called a jigsaw after a jigsaw
puzzle where you actually empower people
to teach each other in other words
they're each putting a piece together of
the puzzle so everybody learns from each
other and you're right i i i've
experienced this in my own life
you really learn something when you have
to teach somebody else how to do it or
or how to think that way and empowering
others to do that and again not just in
an academic classroom setting i think
this applies to how we run meetings how
we run teams in the business world as
well so thank you for that insight now i
know your podcast ends a little
different than mine but i'm hoping
you're willing to answer the same three
questions that i ask every guest on this
podcast are you guys up for that of
course so jonathan if you were to
capture the best communication advice
you ever received as a five to seven
word presentation slide title
what would it be keep things simple oh i
love it and i love how simple that was
you only use three words i gave you five
to seven and you only use three talk to
me a little bit more why simplicity is
so important first of all i would say
all complicated concepts i actually have
a simple core and if they don't there's
probably something wrong but the other
thing is people don't learn complicated
concepts it's too difficult we only
learn simple stuff so you know if you
think you're going to get up there and
explain something
very complicated to somebody and they're
going to walk away and learn it you're
just fooling yourself
so and obviously simple is relative you
know what's simple to a theoretical
physicist and physics integrity is
simple to me
but at every level you have to keep it
simple if i can add to that so i think
it's important also for groups
to set a culture
where simplicity is rewarded i think
that there are certain settings where
over complicating things people think
that it makes them sound intelligent and
makes them look better but i think in
the end nobody is helped with that
approach i absolutely appreciate what
you both are saying and i think it's
really cool that you think this way too
because
if you can simplify something and and to
me i like to use the word accessible
maybe more than simplify but if you can
make something accessible take it down
to to the the most basic elements you
can really help people learn and what it
requires from your perspective
is you really have to think through what
the other person knows and needs in
order to get it to that simplified
accessible point so it's not just about
saying it as simply as possible it's
really about the thought process
beforehand
that helps you do that so i
i love keep it simple now let me ask
both of you this question uh who is a
communicator that you admire and why in
jules why don't you go first
my favorite communicator is keith
jarrett who is one of the best jazz
pianists in the world and he that and he
doesn't even need words to do it i think
that there are things that music and
particularly improvisation can
communicate that no other language can
communicate i am a huge fan of
improvisation we've spent a few episodes
talking to experts on improv and i i
think you're right those who who have
the ability
to
put things together in the moment can
communicate in ways that are just
fantastic to participate in as an
audience and and be it spoken or playing
the piano it's fantastic jonathan i'm
curious who do you admire and why well i
mean i wish i had as great announcers
jules i mean i i i think michael lewis
is a phenomenal communicator
i think he can take uh pretty
complicated concepts and make them very
simple
and communicate them very effectively
jules our final question for you what
are the first three ingredients that go
into a successful communication recipe
so i would say the first ingredient to
effective communication is listening so
unless you have at least some basic
understanding what the person you're
talking to is thinking or often
particularly in the educational setting
struggling with what you're going to say
is not going to arrive so you first have
to figure out what is going on in the
head of the other person so that's
ingredient one i would say the second
ingredient is the one we just mentioned
which is simplicity
i think that there are certain academic
fields that seem to go out of their way
to say things in the most complicated
way possible and i think this just
serves as a barrier to entry for people
not belonging to the in-crowd but in the
end it doesn't help either the people in
the outcrowd but also even the people in
the in-crowd are not helped because if
you want to get new ideas
new ideas are very rare and to get new
ideas you need a lot of people to engage
in the conversation particularly
qualified people so why would you put up
barriers to entry particularly in
language to keep people out i don't
think that's effective and then finally
the third ingredient i would say is uh
also again in an educational setting is
humility and what i mean with that is
in the end i think it's important to
take yourself out of the equation
in the sense that
in the end the only measure of success
that you have as an educator is how much
more the students know or have learned
is even a better way than just knowing
have learned at the end of your course
the rest is irrelevant the
idea of listening and being clear
accessible and simple
very very important but the last point
about humility i think is fundamental
and not only is it in education but just
i think in all communication it's not
about you it's about the people you're
speaking to and what they can do with
the information you're providing and
that that understanding is really
critical you know jonathan and jules i i
knew this was going to be fun and
exciting thank you so much you've
provided us with so many insights and so
many ideas to help us make better
decisions i encourage everyone listening
to listen into their podcast all else
equal best of luck to both of you and
congratulations thanks so much matt
thank you very much man it's been a lot
of fun
[Music]
thanks for joining us for another
episode of think fast talk smart the
podcast produced by stanford
university's graduate school of business
for more information and episodes visit
gsb.stanford.edu
or subscribe to our show wherever you
get your podcasts
finally find us on social media at
stanford.gsb